you had such a fascinating
um
upbringing and and childhood and I've
always had this theory that if
someone is challenged when they're
growing up
and doesn't have a clear sense of their
own identity because it's always being
shifted around that that can be an
impetus to great things even if it's
unpleasant to go through at the time and
you you you grow up in India but then
you move to Nigeria at a pretty young
age yeah my parents can smell happiness
and the minute I find it they move me
like somewhere somewhere else so you
know what they were doing they were like
we want him to be really funny so uh he
seems happy right now move him right
into and stress him so privileged
household in India
um and then get moved to Lagos Nigeria
where I get my ass whooped every week
because I'm the kid from India and I do
uh Public School in Lagos Nigeria and
just as that's going really really well
I'm like nine years old
private boarding school in India where I
get my passport because I'm the kid from
Africa oh my God then finally find a
girlfriend I think in private school in
India get taken to public school in New
Delhi which is where you get your ass
book because you're the kid from Private
School uh
then American University where you're
the kid from India go back to be in
Bollywood where you're the kid from
American drama school and now in La
where you're the guy from Bollywood
you know I fit in and I do apologize for
attacking you earlier when you walked in
I started hitting you I just saw it yeah
because your parents called me and they
said he's getting he's happy again it's
time yes uh so how miserable were you
when you were sent off to private school
I I uh went to public school so I never
had that experience of being sent out
sent away yeah uh at a young age and I
know famously I mean there's people that
write about it it always sounds
dickensian to me like a level of uh you
know you're very young and you're sent
off to another country often and that
there's harsh treatment and I think it
just sounds like a nightmare for kids it
is I was my parents were in Africa and I
was seven so seven and a half when I
went to boarding school in India oh my
God and you know so I was also very
Dramatics I would write them letters in
like red ink and be like this is in my
blood you've forgotten about me
you know oh my God
and then wow you know then you know kids
would try and run away from boarding
school on a weekly basis and because
we're shitty friends we'd like walk them
to the gate of the school and like give
them five bucks and be like good luck
man like I hope you make it but like my
parents were in Africa and I try to run
away from India to Africa like four
times from going School technically hard
to do very hard to do
so so you would take off would you how
far would you get like 3 3 kilometers
but I feel like boarding school either
graduates like generic boarding school
people who you can recognize a mile away
right or like complete Misfits and I'm
the second there was this uh I was
reading them biography of Churchill who
always kind of fascinates me and when he
was very young his parents of course
were you know uh no you know
quasi-noble and they were his father was
a very important person and
um they he was sent away at an absurdly
young age yeah and he always had minders
so he never really saw much of his
parents and his father is a famous
politician and one day and he's very
bitter about the fact he's been sent
away to this very tough English private
school and then he finds out one day
that his father's in that town giving a
speech his town his tiny little town
where his school is in his dad didn't
stop by and visit him and I was reading
the letter and it was like dear father
is I'm hard-pressed to think of why you
couldn't at least wave at my window of
course the father was like you bugger
off I'm time for this but that's what it
always sounds like to me I'm prepping
you to defeat Hitler
like that's what you need to defeat
Hitler yes we do need someone to stand
up to Hitler about 40 years from now and
you're going to be the guy and the only
way to get there is to uh totally treat
you poorly right now it's really sad I
uh I kind of pushed myself out of
boarding school in a very disturbing way
so so we were an ex British Military
Academy it's like 150 year old school
and we had these things called
Headmasters cards and you get three
you're kicked out and I decided by age
12 like I'm done and uh my fan my friend
had appendicitis and his appendix had
ruptured and so one day I just went into
the nurse's office and I'm like I have
appendicitis and she's like okay where
does it hurt and I said here where it
hurt for my friend spent like two days
in the hospital just eating ice cream
and then in the middle of the night they
were like we're taking you to a
different city you're gonna get operated
on oh God and I was like okay and then
I'm in an ambulance and then the next
thing I know I'm on an operation table
right with two doctors who are like you
sure this hurts and I'm like yeah
right you stuck to it no and and then my
parents were in Africa at this point
right and so I wake up after anesthesia
uh like 18 hours later my mother from
Africa is sitting in the hospital in the
north of India and her and two doctors
look very pissed off and they're just
like his appendix was fine and then the
boarding school was just like I don't
think he's happy here maybe you should
pick him out so they opened you up yeah
pretty much you went under anesthesia
and they opened you up they still took
out my appendix to be safe like just
because you know that they were in there
if you're in there you might as well but
yeah that's
they also they also took out a lung yeah
we're here one looks fine but who knows
maybe one day we'll just take it so wow
so that got your parents attention
though yeah and then I was sent off to
public school where
um you know it was a better Journey like
I think I was more man for public school
okay so when's the moment it's always
fascinates me when you figure out I'm
funny I have a superpower
I think
comedians either come from the coolest
kid in school or the most bullied kid in
school are usually Comics right yeah and
the coolest kids
adventure to say have less longevity in
in comedy than the bullied kid and I
just remember being the kid who would
get his ass beat because he couldn't
shut up and then
not being able to shut up during the
beating you know what I mean like where
I'd be like what is this really
accomplishing does this make you feel
better and I wouldn't shut up and then
sometimes the guy beating you would
Crack A Smile as well you know and you'd
be like yeah I think this is funny uh I
I think I have to admit you're pretty
funny now where was I in the beating
yeah uh yeah I I think so it you start
to notice I think a lot of times you
start to notice it with your friends
yeah if you have any friends you can I
always think that's where it starts uh
and that you can make your friends laugh
and then it's a a thing of how can I
move how can I widen this circle a
little bit slowly
um to include other people who aren't my
friends uh but I I like doing this so
much I like making people laugh how can
I expand out from there I think so but I
also think making your friends laugh is
sometimes like a disservice to Comedy as
well like you know the the first time I
ended up doing stand up I was in college
and it was like my last year and I'd
gone through like four years of drama
school so four years of sitting in a
circle and crying and holding hands and
doing things like emoting with your
shoulders or whatever the hell they tell
you to do in drama school
I've noticed you emote exclusively with
your shoulders it's a lot of motion the
basis of Bollywood my friend is emoting
with your shoulders
oh you're right yeah wow okay all right
and uh I ended up writing like as a
almost Rebellion this show remember
there was a movie called White Men Can't
Jump yes so I wrote a show called Brown
men can't hump uh in my final year of
college and so the first time I did
stand up it was like 65 minutes for 800
people wow and all friends you know
every so just inside stories and you
feel like you're like I'm the I'm
amazing at this cut to you at an open
mic in Chicago like three weeks after
graduation getting booed off stage and
you discovered no I need to be able to
make strangers laugh yes as well